[Música]
esta impresionante nube de humo negro
proviene de un incendio en el basurero
de salvi en el distrito de a jara de
kuwait este lugar es considerado como el
mayor cementerio de neumáticos del mundo
en este lugar donde hay cerca de 60
millones de neumáticos usados suele
haber este tipo de accidentes estos son
documentados de manera regular en
imágenes como este vídeo que fue grabado
en la primavera pasada pero que fue
publicado este verano nuestra
observadora es una ingeniera de kuwait y
ella explica los peligros de estos
basureros para el medio ambiente en su
país
las investigaciones han revelado que son
incendios provocados no son accidentes
cuando la basura se quemó se deja sin
tratar durante mucho tiempo libera
elementos tóxicos
este es el caso de todos los consumibles
industriales como el plástico o el
caucho sintético con el que se fabrican
los neumáticos
la combustión de estos neumáticos libera
carbono negro el peor tipo de carbono
además el kuwait no tenemos una buena
gestión de los residuos
y los basureros están mal distribuidos
algunos están en medio de zonas
residenciales
por eso los habitantes de estas zonas
padecen enfermedades respiratorias en
los años 80 y 90 cv white e importó
cientos de millones de neumáticos usados
desde eeuu y europa con el fin de
reciclar los el emirato se vio
desbordado los neumáticos más recientes
debían ser enterrados pero muchos
permanecen en la superficie de unos
basureros ya saturados el estado de
kuwait no adopta el reciclaje y opta por
enterrar sus residuos ni siquiera
tenemos los medios para reciclar
cantidades tan grandes de neumáticos al
menos no los suficientes hay 18
basureros en el país 14 de los cuales
están cerrados en kuwait el 90% de los
residuos no se reciclan y los desechos
representan el 3% de la superficie total
del país
esta es brenda dama es una empleada
doméstica de 26 años hace dos años se
fue de kenia para trabajar como empleada
doméstica en una familia de arabia
saudita ahora es una estrella de 'tik
tok' con 32 mil suscriptores brenda
documenta la dura realidad del día a día
del trabajo doméstico en oriente medio
esta es una forma de aliviar la soledad
de los trabajadores domésticos que
algunas veces están a miles de
kilómetros de sus casas
y otros trabajadores domésticos publican
vídeos sobre el sufrimiento que padecen
en arabia saudita
cual quiero proponer los vídeos que
puedan motivarlos
para hacerles sentir que los a los
únicos que pasan por estas situaciones
[Música]
abuela
también publicó vídeos para que nuestros
jefes los vean porque ellos también
están en dictar
nuestras jefas y jefes
así que si subo vídeos que los eduquen
sobre cómo deberíamos ser tratados
[Música]
eso es esclavitud moderna esto es lo que
vivimos no puedo mentir sobre cómo nos
tratan en algunas casas
trabajamos muchas horas desde la mañana
hasta quizás las 10 de la noche
a veces 12 horas al día sin descanso
a veces descansamos un poco pero casi
siempre estamos muy ocupados he visto a
gente volverse loca obviamente es por lo
que viven aquí
incluso si la persona es fuerte
mentalmente
alguien que viene aquí puede volverse
loco después de un tiempo
el pasado mes de marzo arabia saudita
introdujo reformas en materia de mano de
obra migrante pero estos cambios no
pusieron fin al abusivo sistema de caf a
la que otorga a los empleadores poder
sobre la movilidad del estatus legal de
los trabajadores domésticos extranjeros
en ese país lo que tienen que cambiar y
dicen que ya lo están haciendo es el
sistema de caffa lab
en el que una persona concreta te trae
este país
y se queda con todos tus documentos
hasta que se supone que debes volver a
casa
si quieres cambiar de empleador es un
proceso difícil
certificado process
algunos vuelven a sus casas pero no es
fácil es muy duro porque una vez que
estás bajo mucha atención con tu
empleador decides
basta no quiero seguir trabajando en
arabia saudita quiero volver a casa
puedes irte pero estarás en la oficina
de reclutamiento durante mucho tiempo
aunque algunas empleadas domésticas han
tenido problemas para publicar vídeos
similares en redes sociales
brendan nos dijo que nunca ha tenido
problemas con sus empleadores
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 no duden en
escribirnos para contarnos todo lo que
ocurre muy cerca de ustedes todos
nuestros contactos aparecen en sus
pantallas esperamos sus fotos y también
sus vídeos para contar sus historias a
nuestros televidentes en américa latina
y brasil hasta pronto